[موسيقى]
الزميل المقصود هو طلب الاستقاله قرار فصل
الاسباب التي ذكرتها اللجنه ونرى انها
كانت يعني
الزميل نفسه
نظام داخلي في دستور في في مخاطبات
المفروض ان نتبعها الا
ان لا نقوم بتوجيه خطابات دون ان يكون
هناك مراعاه للظروف البلد وان تكون فيها
مصداقيه لما يقول وبعدين الناس انتخبونا
حتى نحضر الجلسات ونبدي راينا داخل قبه
مجلس النواب اللي مسموح الكلام مسموع فيها
همم
بحريه مطلقه وتستطيع ان تتحدث همم
بكامل بكامل ما تريده بكل القوات وكذلك
ايضا همم الدستور الدستور النظام الداخلي
اتاهلنا بعث الاسئله المختلفه وعن الحكومه
خلال 15 يوم ان تجيب على هذه الاسديه خلال
ما وضعه الدستور نستطيع ان نحصل على
المعلومه الدقيقه وننقولها الى الشارع
بشكل دقيق بدلا من تكون عشوائي وفيه
اتهامات همم بعيده عن الحقيقه وعن الصواب
لا شك ان قرار اللجنه كان قرارا غير
قانوني ولا ينسجن مع الضمانات الاساسيه
والمحاكمه العادله التي نص عليها الدستور
والتشييعات المعمول بها وما ورد في العهد
الدولي الخاص بالحقوق المدنيه والسياسيه
وخاصه الماده 14 من اعطاء ضمانه كامله لاي
شخص يتم تقديم شكوى هذه القضيه تحتاج الى
تاني وسماع شهاده مشتكي عليه الا يجوز ان
نسمعته
وكان يتوجب ارسال الشكوى له ويجاوب عليها
ويحدد له موعد للحضور ويقال له انه من حقه
التوكيل محامي والدفاع عن نفسه واما القول
الله اتصلنا مع هاتف هذا غير كافي قطعيا
غير كافي لما قالوا النظام الداخلي
99 من اعضاء مجلس النواب يجب ان يتحول الى
مجلس لانه في عنده وبعد كان 20 و25 و30
ويغيبوا شهر وعشرين وعشره وثلاثه واربعه
ما اخذ ما تم حسم ولا على نائب واحد احنا
يجب ان نكون دوله مؤسسات والقانون محترم
مبدا الفصل بين السلطات لهذا القرار لم
يكن هناك مبدا الفصل بين السلطه مبدا
الفصل بين الصيان الحريه ومنع الاستبداد
لا يجوز ان تغور سلطه على سلطه اليوم
شعرنا ان سلطه التشريعيه تغولت على السلطه
القضائيه بانها حكمت بظل واستندت الى
قانون العقوبات الاردني ولا يحق لها في
مخالفه مسلكيه في فرق بين العقوبه
المسلكيه
[موسيقى]